So here was a question, a good question came in, get our cancer diet guideline notebook.
It states that natural sweeters should be used in place of sugar, but limited.
How much is limited?
Is it appropriate for one substitution acceptable?
Eat as a comp of sugar, use an acceptable substitution for the comp of sugar.
Is that okay?
Still making cookies that way.
What is considered too much?
How much stevia, which is labeled in an notebook as acceptable?
Is that to be treated any different than the other natural sweeters?
Wonderful question.
So usually this is gone over by the person who went over your three rig binder, but I
know it's like drinking from a fire hose on your second day here.
Sometimes you don't hear everything and it doesn't all get registered.
But you have to understand that even good natural sweeters, like, oh, can I drink?
Can I eat all the raw honey that I want?
Can I eat all the manuka honey that I want because it's natural?
Can I eat all the pure maple syrup that I want or coconut palm sugar?
The answer is no, you can't, because still though these are natural sweeters, they're still
going to break down to glucose.
So here's a picture, just pulled off the internet of the glycemic index, that means the rate
at things break down in the glucose.
Well, of course glucose breaks down in the glucose.
It is glucose.
Table sugar is sucrose that is, you know, two sugar molecules together and they break down,
it breaks down to glucose very quickly.
And then like the Arithritol, Manitol, and these sugar alcohols are down here at, they have
a very low glycemic index, but that doesn't necessarily mean that they're healthy sugars
to eat constantly.
So is it okay?
We have some bars from one of the supplement companies that we have in our break room here
that uses Arithritol as its sweetener, so it has a very low glycemic index, so it's very
good for diabetic patients, but still eating Arithritol all the time, a sugar alcohol all
the time, and thinking that you're doing good for your body is not really a truism.
Is it okay to eat one of those a couple of times a week?
Yeah, it's not going to be any problem, but if you're eating a couple of day thinking you're
not raising your glucose levels, well, you really aren't raising your glucose levels,
but it is hard for your body to break down the sugar alcohol, so it's not something that's
supposed to be, but so when we say limited, you have to cut a use of common sense there.
So common sense is based upon information, so that's what I want to do here.
When I use natural sweeters like raw honey and pure maple syrup on a daily basis, well,
if your diet that we put you on was a more ketogenic-like diet, where we took you off of a lot
of carbs where we're limiting your grains, then you have to strongly limit these natural
sweeters.
Let's leave stevey out of here, but let's talk about raw honey, pure maple syrup, monk fruit
and coconut palm sugar.
These will still break down to glucose, stevey will not break down to glucose.
So these four will still break down to glucose, so we want to limit that.
So what does that word limited mean?
Well, if you're on a more ketogenic diet, so if a person's on a true ketogenic diet, you're
not eating any of those.
If you're on a keto-like diet, which we put most our patients on, if you had those once
a week, I'd say that would be acceptable.
If you're not on that and you're on a mixed diet where you're decreasing some of the proteins
and we have you, everybody's off of sugar, but we're not limiting your other complex carbs.
If you had this a couple of times a week, that would be fine.
So if you decided to make some cookies out of almond flour and coconut palm sugar, could
you have a couple of little cookies, sure, could you eat the whole batch of cookies, no.
So I can't, I'm not here to give you how many cookies you could eat or how many grams
of this that you want to stick to, but you have to use some common sense.
If you eat too much of any of these things other than stevey, you're going to raise your glucose
levels and you're just feeding your cancer.
So part of this has to do with just, okay, we could eat some raw honey, but that doesn't
mean we're going to substitute it, we're not, we're going to just make all our own cookies
now out of flowers that are carbohydrates and honey that is a simple carbohydrate and think
that we're not raising our blood sugar.
What other thing is that you can do because everybody's body is different than how you respond
to these things, is you could get yourself a glucometer, a glucometer, if you don't know
what that is, is a little teeny device that you could buy a target that has little strips
in it, that you could prick your finger and test your blood sugar.
So you can wake up in the morning and test your blood sugar, to many of you, I'm told to
do this.
And you let's say at a fasting 12 hour state, your blood sugar is 85, that's really good.
So it's 85 and then you eat breakfast and it bounces up to 170.
So if you ate breakfast in 20 minutes after breakfast, your blood sugar would up to 170, it's
a pretty good chance that you had way too many carbohydrates in your breakfast.
So did you eat waffles with syrup on it, well it was pure maple syrup, well I know, but
it was three tablespoons of pure maple syrup on the waffles, that's all carbohydrates,
it just spiked your blood sugar, that's not good.
So two hours after eating 80 meal, your blood sugar should drop back down to normal.
So it's let's say you ate it eight o'clock and it's 11 o'clock and you test your blood sugar,
three hours after you eat and your blood sugar is still over 100, you're probably spiking
your glucose to high.
So that's another way that you can test your own, you know, I is my glucose level is my
carbohydrate level exceeding really my body's ability to bring it back under control because
all these things, this is why we say limited because we can't give you strict data because
your body may be different.
So it has to do with your pancreas ability to produce insulin and then your cell membranes
ability to receive the insulin to get the glucose out of the bloodstream.
So if you get your glucose back in normal ranges, meaning a perfect normal range would be 75
to 90, that would be a perfect normal fasting glucose range, 75 to 90 if you're not in a key
genetic state, then you two hours post-friend two hours post-eating, your glucose is down
back to 89, you're doing great.
So you did a good job with being able to regulate that glucose back down.
If you want more help on this, then give our office a call and we can walk through your situation
directly.
You have to remember with any glucose, so any food that you're eating, so food that's
breaking down the glucose, remember glucose is the sugar, so all your carbohydrates are
going to break down to glucose, better your proteins are going to break down to glucose.
It goes through a process here that is in this arrow here called glycolysis, it's a whole
bunch of steps in here and one of the purposes of glycolysis, it gives off energy, it gives
off two ATP's and that the end point of glycolysis is this chemical called pyruvate, pyruvate
is very important, it's the end point of glycolysis and then pyruvate is supposed to convert
through this enzyme called the PDH enzyme, this is the gene that makes that enzyme into
this very important chemical called acetyl coenzyme.
Acetyl coenzyme is the entry point for the crem cycle, why do I need to know all this stuff
because this is how your body makes energy.
You take in food, you break it down into glucose, it breaks down into pyruvate makes two
energy molecules, it converts through this gene, that's why when we look at your genetics,
we look at that gene and we look at the HIF1 gene, because these genes are so important
in breaking down pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme, because acetyl coenzyme sends it into the crem
cycle and this is where you really kick out energy, this takes place in the mitochondria
of the cell here, so the mitochondria of the cell, this is what's taking place.
In cancer patients, not all cancer patients, but many cancer patients, so when we test you
and you test high on pyruvate with adhesiology, or we look at your genetics and you have defects
in your PDH gene and your HIF genes, then you're going to be more apt to not be able to convert
pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme, well what's the big deal about that, well it is a big deal
because you will convert pyruvate to lactic acid and that's what feeds cancer, it also can cause
diabetes and liver problems, but it's a made food source of cancer, right there,
lactate, lactic acid, pyruvate or pyruvate acid will convert to lactate with defects in the
PDH gene and defects in the HIF gene and when you have excess glucose coming through glycolysis
and it's unable to make this conversion, this conversion takes some time.
Matter of fact, if you really want to get technical about this,
when you are first starting to get in shape, oh, I think I need to get in shape,
well what is the last time you exercise Dr. Cutters? Well, it was a high school,
okay, so this is going to be a process that's getting in shape, maybe we better start running,
oh no no no, I used to run cross coaching in high school, so I'm going to start running right away,
so I go by myself so running to choose and I'm going to start running and I get about a block
before I'm ready to throw out and pass out, but I push through it because I remember my days
in high school that I was really a good runner and I don't want to look silly to the people who are
sitting out in their garage watching me run by their driveway, so I keep pushing it on, holding back
my stomach and I push on and I run three blocks before I'm ready to coax out and a kid
figure out why I am so sore the next day, you know where that sortus comes from?
The sortus comes from, when you use your muscles that you haven't used like that for a long time,
your muscles need energy, so in order for your muscles to continue to contract in the act of a workout,
it's a calling for energy, where do you get energy? You get energy through glycolysis,
kick it out, ATP, and then converting pyruvate into acetylco enzyme A,
go into the crab cycle and kick it out a whole bunch of ATP, so that's energy, so your muscles are
calling for that process to take place, it's sucking glucose from your blood, well that's what we want,
right? That would be really good, it's converting it to pyruvate, and then this process through the
PDH gene is time restricted, so this process takes time, so the conversion from pyruvate
to acetylco enzyme A takes time, and the less you use this pathway, the slower it is,
so I haven't really used this pathway very extensively since high school in my muscles, so this is not
converted to acetylco enzyme A, and it will remain in my muscles as pyruvate.
The problem is, is pyruvate, or pyruvic acid, is poisonous, and if you have excess pyruvate,
you die, so your body has this ingenious way to protect you, it converts pyruvate
through the LDH gene to lactate, so pyruvate converts to lactic acid, and the purpose is lactic acid
makes you sore, so muscle fatigue, muscle paid post workout is because of excess lactic acid in the muscles,
because I'm not very good shape, this pathway here hasn't been stimulated very much in my muscles,
now the more I work out, so tomorrow I'm going to work out, and I'm going to be more reasonable,
and I'm just going to walk, and then jog a block, and then walk a couple more blocks, and the next day,
I'm going to walk, and jog a block, and walk a couple more blocks, and the next day, I'm going to walk,
and jog two blocks, and I'm going to keep this up, and over the course of the next four months,
I'm able to convert glucose to pyruvate, and pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme more efficiently,
so the more efficient my muscles become at converting pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme is called
Gideated Shape, so the Gideated Shape, so what you say, are you in good shape? Yeah, I ran a 5K,
and my time is getting better, now I could do it in 32 minutes, or now I could do it in 21 minutes,
that process of Gideated Shape, literally, is your ability to convert pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme
more quickly? Why is that important? Well, it is important with cancer patients,
because the inability to do so will produce more fuel for a cancer.
So that brings us back to the angel question, should a cancer patient exercise?
It might statement to cross the board for a long time, it's been yes, but do it gently,
and do something you enjoy, because we don't want to go, oh, I think cancer patients should
exercise, so I'm going to go jump on the treadmill and do something stupid like I typically do,
thinking about I'm going to relive my glory days of high school when I could run a 5K at 16 minutes.
Well, that ain't ever happening again, so let's be realistic, and we don't want to produce all
this lactic acid in a short period of time, thinking that this is how I'm going to get in shape,
and I got to really push it, that's not the way to do it. You want to work out very slowly,
so you're not getting sore, so instead of taking four months to be able to run a 5K,
it would be great, if all my cancer patients could run a 5K, that would be wonderful,
they're really good at pushing this pathway. However, if you haven't been in that position,
we want to take instead of four months to get in shape, maybe a year or a half to get in shape.
Be more patient so that we're not producing a bunch of lactic acid. Does that make sense?
I know that question was about sugar, and how can we eat natural sweeteners,
but I tend to think on metabolic pathways, and why you would want to or not do something.
So the more sugar that you eat, and that you're not exercising, you're not even pulling this pathway,
so the muscles aren't even exercising. This is why we tend to get fat when we eat a whole bunch of
sugar, and it's not even producing any energy, because the muscles are calling for energy. Also,
this is how we can feed cancer, but we're eating things that break down to glucose, which is
any carbohydrates, and things like raw honey and maple syrup are going to be higher on the glycemic
index meeting. They'll break down to sugar even more quickly, and if I'm not using that sugar to
produce energy, my cancer is going to use it to make more cancer cells. So hopefully that answered
that question, even with more information that you ever wanted to know. Next question. When the liver
empties itself during a coffee in a, where do the toxins go? Does this require 2.5 deep
tox effort? Also, other than minerals, add a lot of water for the sun, a sweating detox. Does the
body need extra help there as well? Good question. So let's just make something really clear. When you do
a coffee in a, it doesn't magically cause your liver to detoxify. It helps support detoxification
mainly by stimulating the vagal nerve, the cranial nerve, 10 in the sigmoid colon. So that is
going to stimulate phase 1, phase 2, phase 2.5 detox detoxification neurologically. So does that mean
you still need support for phase 2? If I have PMTG defects that is decreasing by ability to make
colon, so I'm not getting bile production. Do I need support with phase 1 with maybe taking milk
thistle? So all those things need to be assessed with kinesiology or with something that we could
measure that your detox is going the way that it wants to go, that way that we want it to go.
Do you need extra minerals? If you're sweating, if you're doing a sauna, I think that's what she's
alluded to to this question. If I'm doing a sauna on a daily basis and I'm sweating out my minerals,
do I need to be taking extra minerals? Yes, possibly. It depends on partially how much you're
sweating. It depends on whether you're sweating other than doing the sauna. It depends on what your
diet is, too, because we really want you to get most of your nutrients through your diet. So if your
diet is if you're using a greens product, if you're juicy, if you're eating a lot of vegetables and
there are organic sources, that you might be getting plenty of minerals. So if we're really concerned
about that, it might be good to do a basic comfort. It's a metabolic panel. It's a blood test to make
sure that our electrolytes are not thrown off. We certainly don't want that. But you can certainly
take some minerals and again refer back to the video that I talked about, that talks about good minerals
versus bad minerals and how they need to be keylated, etc. But taking a mineral supplement,
there's nothing wrong with doing that. You really can't hold down it,
increasing magnesium as a minerals, your mineral source as well as important that can help keep
your bottles loose as well. Next question I want to let you know that I have had continual paid
right below my left rib. I wonder if my liver was overloaded. So I've been doing two coffee
edamas a day, noticing a lot more hard black specks in my morning bowel movements,
and quite a few liver flukes maybe after my evening edema. I'm glad to be getting them out. First of all,
a little bit of anatomy. Your liver, really where you'll feel liver paid is going to be over the
under the right rib, typically not the left rib. Even though part of your liver is under your left side,
you're going to feel more split issues there. If you have paid underneath your left rib,
most likely it's colon, not liver. So I wouldn't think that paid under your left rib is liver. So
that would not be my go-to. I would think that could be colon. Make sure you just, and I've told many
of you before, sometimes it's good to put a little oil, massage oil or coconut oil on your tummy,
in rub, your tummy. It could be good to have your partner maybe knead your belly like they're
making a loaf of bread. It could be very healthful. There's a technique called bloodless surgery.
There was actually a book. I think it's out of print now, written by a major doctor,
Djardé. He was one of my instructors. He was like 80s, 90s when he was my instructor back in the
early 80s. But he was just a master at that. And I learned from him that technique of
manipulating your viscera from the outside in a form of what's called bloodless surgery. So
that massage technique is a very old Chinese acupuncture technique as well that you could really
help get your bowels moving. And I mean, I think you got 30 feet of intestines in that tummy of yours,
including your stomach, including your liver, including your spleen, and other ovaries and
uterus. I mean, there's a lot of stuff going on there. So movie that around could be very helpful
in a massage-like way. Black specks in your stool. That could be so many different things there. I
don't know where to go on that. Liver flutes are very small. So is it possible that you can see
liver flutes? Yes, liver flutes are a parasite that probably the majority of people in the world have
liver flutes. And you can see those in your stool as well. Next question. I'm getting leg cramps.
So this kind of ties back to that literal question of after doing sonas. I'm getting leg cramps
during the night. Do I need more potassium in the diet? I don't think I'm behind it. I drink a lot
of water during the day. Any suggestions for this? Well, leg cramps at night, I just pulled this
little ditty off the website. If you're exercising rigorously, you could have leg cramps. Why?
Because you have lactic acid milled up in your muscles. If you have any hormonal or fluid
imbalances, electrolytic balances, this is exactly what this person is referring to. Do I need more
potassium in my diet? Dehydration could cause this. Any neurological issues could cause this as well.
Well, that's just talk about the most common thing. The most common thing is what this person is
alluded to, an electrolyte of balance. So understand. So your electrolytes are very important to keep
in balance. That is basically your mineral content of your blood. And if they go out of balance,
what are the first symptoms is going to be restless legs, muscle fatigue, leg cramps, having to wake
up with Charlie Horse. That's the major side of imbalance in your electrolytes. The misconception
that people have is that they think they're dehydrated. That's why they're getting the problem.
And dehydration can cause the problem. But when we drink too much water, that could be even more
so the problem because we're flushing out our electrolytes. So we hear, oh my gosh, we need to be
drinking more water. So I'm drinking 75 ounces of water a day because that's very helpful for me.
Well, it can be, but you could be losing your electrolytes. So if you are flushing out your
electrolytes through drinking too much water, that could be the problem. Again, the only way to know
for sure is to get a blood test. But certainly before getting the blood test, I would just add some
minerals to my diet and see if that makes a difference. Now some people do better drinking less water.
I know if you're Google it, it's say drink half your body weight in water every day. I just don't
like generalities like that because some people do much better drinking much less water than that.
And if they drink more, they flush it out. I've had people that drink two glasses of water a day and
you test their tonal body water on a biometric test and their tonal body water is 60% which is great.
And it's like you only drink two glasses of water a day and I've had people that drink that are
drinking 60 ounces of water a day and basically they're flushed out their electrolytes and they are
causing themselves to be dehydrated because it is your electrolytes that help hold your water and your
tissues. So if you're flushed out your electrolytes, you're just going to pee all the water out and you might
be drinking 60 ounces a day but then you look at your total body water out of biometric test and it's
like 45%. So you're creating a state of dehydration by drinking too much water. So add some minerals that
would be my first suggestion to your diet. You could even add some pink salt or something to your
food. That could be beneficial as a mineral source as well. Next question. Is it normal to be tired or
sleepy after surgery? Is it one's body just slowing down to heal? It can be so it can be normal.
It's your body's a way to just slow you down so that you do heal and that can be the possibility.
You do also want to check anemia. So getting a blood test again, we want to look at that
too tired after surgery. That can be a side of bleed too. So it's a good idea to just get a
comprehensive blood panel by your doctor and send your results in email them to the clinics so I
can look at them because a dbia can be not that uncommon post surgery. So looking at an electrolyte
balance, looking at all those mineral bands, a lot of the questions were similar this week. It's
interesting but that could be important. So I wouldn't just take it as oh it's a good thing I want to
rest. It very well could be but it might be good to get a blood panel done.